we have four different expressions here
what I want you to do is think about
which of these expressions are equal to
negative 2/3 which of these are equal to
negative 2/3 and I encourage you now to
pause this video and try this on your
own
so let's go to this first expression
right over here
I have 1/9 and I'm going to add to that
five ninths so how many ninths am I
going to have well I had 1/9 now I'm
adding five ninths so I'm going to have
six ninths if I have one of something
and I have five more of that same
something so in this case that something
is 1/9 1/9 plus five nines is six ninths
now can we simplify this in any way well
both 6 & 9 are divisible by 3 so let's
divide them both by 3 to try to get this
fraction in a simpler form 6 divided by
3 is 2 9 divided by 3 is 3 so this is
2/3
while what we're trying to get to is
negative 2/3 so these are not equal this
expression does not equal not equal
negative 2/3 so I'll write no for that
one now let's go to this this green
expression right over here give myself a
little bit more real estate to work in
now we have negative 1/6 plus negative
1/2 now we can view this as being the
same thing as just to clarify right now
the negative is in front of the entire
1/6 the negatives in front of the entire
1/2 but this is the same thing as
negative 1 over 6 plus negative 1 over
negative 1 over 2 negative 1/2 is the
same thing as negative 1/2 is one way to
think about it and the whole reason why
I did this is so we can simplify what
the- the negatives are right now only in
our numerator so whenever we had two
fractions we want to have this that we
want to have the same denominator and we
see that 6 is already a multiple of 2 so
we could leave this first fraction the
way it is we can rewrite it as negative
1 over 6 and then the second fraction we
can write it as something over 6 well to
go from 2 to 6 we have to multiply by 3
so let's also multiply the numerator by
3 negative 1 times 3 is
negative three so if I have negative one
sixths and I add to that negative three
six this is going to be negative 1 plus
negative 3 6 which is equal to negative
4 over 6 now let's see if we can
simplify it both negative 4 or I guess
we can say both 4 & 6 are divisible by 2
so let's divide them both by 2 let's
divide them both by 2 and in the
numerator we're left with negative 4
divided by 2 is negative 2 6 divided by
2 is 3 negative 2 divided by 3 well
that's the same thing as negative 2/3
which is exactly what we're going to get
to so yes this thing in green is equal
to negative 2/3 now let's go over here
so we have negative 1/3 times negative 2
well if you multiply negative times a
negative we're going to get a positive
and we're going to get a positive 1/3
times 2 so one way to think about it
this is going to be the same thing as
1/3 times 2 which is the same thing and
there's a couple of ways to think about
it if you have 1/3 and now you're going
to have you're gonna multiply it by 2
you now have 2/3 you now have 2/3
another way to think about this is that
this is the same thing as 1/3 times 2
over 1 and you know that we can just
multiply that when we multiply two
fractions so this time we've expressed
the 2 as a fraction we can multiply
their numerators so it's 1 times 2 over
the product of their denominators 3
times 1 which is 2 over 3 so either way
you look at it this goes to positive 2/3
a negative times a negative is a
positive so it gets this to positive 2/3
not negative 2/3 so like this first one
no it does not it does not equal it does
not equal negative 2/3 now let's look at
this one negative 1/3 divided by 1/2 so
when you divide by a fraction so when
you divide when you take negative 1/3
dividing let me write it this way so
negative 1/3 divided by 1/2 this is the
same thing as negative 1/3 and let me
let me color
just so you see what I'm doing so make
that that green color let me make this a
blue color so negative 1/3 divided by
1/2 is the same thing as negative 1/3
times the reciprocal of 1/2 so x times 2
over 2 over 1 2 over 1 and what is this
going to be equal to well we look we can
assume instead of just going this is
negative 1/3 we could view this as
negative 1/3 that might help us keep
track of the signs a little bit more and
so if we do this is let me actually let
me write it that way just to make it a
little bit clearer let me write this as
let me write this as negative 1/3 so our
numerator is now going to be our
numerator it's now going to be negative
1 times 2 when you multiply two
fractions you just multiply the
numerator to get the new the new
numerator multiply the two numerators to
get the new numerator and it's over 3
times 1/3 times 1 and you know you
normally wouldn't have to do all of
these steps but I'm just doing them to
make sure you understand what's going on
and so this is going to be equal to
negative 1 times 2 is negative 2
negative 2 and 3 times 1 is positive 3
negative 2 over 3 well that's the same
thing that's the same thing as negative
2/3 so this one works out it is equal to
negative 2/3